foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in uh our good buddy Ross
Tucker who joins us now Westwood One CBS
analyst Ross is going to be on the call
tonight he'll be in the booth with Kevin
Harlan commanders Eagles Westwood One
radio okay yeah I know all right and you
guys said he'd never amount to anything
yeah you you did it you're you're got a
big Monday night game you're going to be
there with Kevin Harlan who's always
excited fritzy get get Ross in the mood
give him a little Kevin Harlan and it's
a field goal for the eagles with 12-19
left in the first quarter order
Philadelphia strikes first you're
listening to coverage of the commanders
and Eagles on Westwood One
and just get you ready there that was
awesome that was awesome princess you
know it's funny Dan because tonight's
Western won broadcast there's going to
be an absolutely legendary broadcaster
for CBS and Western one
and there's gonna be Kevin Harlan too
wow you like that
yeah all right by the way the Rams three
and six record the worst nine-game start
by a defending Super Bowl champ since
the Pittsburgh Steelers in 2006 three
other defending Super Bowl champs have
started The Following season three and
six the 1999 Broncos 1987 Giants 1982
49ers what's wrong with the Rams
a lot I mean A lot's wrong with the Rams
right now most of which I would say is
their offensive line has been generally
atrocious the whole year I mean you
start with losing Austin Corbin for
agency the Right Guard Whitworth the
left tackle retires but then even the
guys that they plugged in for them Dan
have been in and out of the lineup
banged up they've got guys starting that
they never would have thought would be
playing for them before the season you
see that in the NFL right like we could
probably go through almost every team
and they have at least one player
starting that not once they talk about
on Sports Talk Radio before the season
or even knew who the guy was but that's
the NFL Rams have had more than their
fair share Stafford's played really
poorly they can't run the ball a lick
um now he didn't even play in this last
game a little bit of a Super Bowl
hangover they miss Odell I could go on
the Vikings and the bills is that more
on what the bills
didn't do and collapsed or more on than
what the Vikings did to be resilient
it's a tough question I I put a lot of
it on the bills I think you do I mean
obviously what Justin Jefferson did with
that catch was incredible maybe the best
catch I've seen Dan given okay Odell
Beckham Jr against the Cowboys or Justin
Jefferson yesterday
so I think Justin Jefferson yesterday
and I was on the sideline for the Odell
one but I think Justin Jefferson because
we've now seen a bunch of guys make like
one hand wild catches it's a totally
different ball game when it's number one
fourth and 18 to end the game and number
two you have another NFL player Dan who
had a better jump on the ball had two
hands on it and was pulling it in I have
no idea how Jefferson had the strength
to power the ball through with one hand
when cam Lewis had two hands on it it's
it's an absolutely incredible that he
made that catch now that being the case
that's a terrible play by cam Lewis it's
Fourth and 18. volleyball spiked that
thing you know that's why I have to say
it's more of a collapse on the bills
you're up 2710 you don't score a touch
touchdown in the second half you don't
score a point in the fourth quarter till
that last field goal you give up an 81
yard touchdown very very rare in the NFL
that's a mistake I didn't like the
decision by McDermott to go for it when
they're up 10 Allen throws the pick a
horrible pick I know he says well it was
fourth down well yeah but part of the
reason there's value in going for it
potentially on fourth down Dan is
because if you don't get it you pin them
deep well if you throw a pick and they
run it out 30 yards you lose that
benefit of going for it on fourth down
which I didn't like and then obviously
the late pick by Alan was bad and the
quarterback sneak that's another one
like those two game situations I'd love
to ask McDermott did he make it clear to
Alan like hey we don't want a safety
here but ball Security First you know
safety's not the worst thing in the
world make sure you secure the ball or
on the fourth and 18 did they tell the
defensive backs to knock it down clearly
they didn't more of a bills meltdown
that a Vikings win although obviously
what the Vikings did was really
impressive
okay is this a standalone game or is
this something that might be a trend
here with the Buffalo Bills
I think it's something that's a trend
with both of these teams
the Vikings I mean they were losing 17-7
in the fourth quarter to Washington last
week wait you're all in on the Vikings
I'm saying that it's a trend both ways
it's a trend that yeah I'm I'm kind of
on the Vikings well you can't be good
you're in on the Vikings
absolutely okay they're a top five team
in the NFL top five team in the NFL okay
Lynn hold on are they are they better
than Kansas City no they better than the
Eagles
no are they better than
the Ravens
they're about right there yeah I'd
probably take them over the Ravens right
now yes and they better than the Niners
yes better than the Buccaneers
yes for sure
they're good okay they're a good
football team I mean they got two really
good receivers they got a stud running
back o-line's playing well cousins is
playing well okay defense is much better
than they were last year they're good
they are trending in the right direction
they'll be top five in the Ross Tucker
podcast Power Rankings tomorrow and the
bills might not be you know now it's
lose back to back games that they
shouldn't have Josh Allen making
critical mistakes at the wrong time and
and now they have an uphill about now
they have an uphill battle Dan just to
win their division let alone trying to
get home field advantage which should be
significant for them in January
I was trying to understand the logic of
Mike McCarthy and I know everybody loves
to use him as a pinata you go back to
Green Bay
and you have a fourth and three and you
go for it if you know you're going to go
for it on Fourth do you change the play
call on third down was was my concern
with that
because it felt like you know hey we're
now we're gonna go for it but I always
think
how about we get the first down so give
me two plays to get the first down and I
don't know if Green Bay had that thought
going into it and then I wondered why
you wouldn't you know kick the field
goal your thoughts
totally agree
Kellen Moore the play caller for the
Cowboys needs to know before the play
hey we're gonna go for it on fourth down
here if we don't get it on third now
maybe that happened Dan we're not there
I don't know I don't know what McCarthy
said but maybe that happened it
certainly didn't seem like it based on
the play call
because you think two downs run the ball
to be able to get three yards because
they were actually running it pretty
effectively with Pollard or you can use
Dax legs I my guess is that that didn't
happen that they decided after third
down let's go for it on fourth down and
I think that's because it would have
been a relatively long field goal and
also because I think McCarthy thought if
we don't score a touchdown Rogers is
going to come down he's hot now he's
finding this kid Watson I think McCarthy
kind of thought I've seen this movie too
many times
he's Ross Tucker he'll be in the booth
tonight if you're listening on Westwood
One radio with Kevin Harlan it'll be the
Eagles against the commanders Colts and
Raiders tell me what Jeff Saturday did
that Frank Reich wasn't doing as head
coach of the Colts
well the most obvious one was starting
Matt Ryan at quarterback which is
ridiculous in the sense that I know you
probably heard this damn but I've had
multiple people tell me Frank Reich was
told by Jim Ursa he had to bench Matt
Ryan to go with Sam Ellinger so let me
get this straight Earth's head first
take three weeks ago tell us right you
got to put Ellinger in a bench Matt Ryan
Reich does it they play terrible he says
you gotta fire the offensive coordinator
Marcus Brady poor guy the next week he
fires him okay they play terrible again
then Wright gets fired Saturday in
Saturday says hey you know what I got
this great idea why don't we play the
quarterback that's been playing for like
15 years actually knows what he's doing
and gives us the best chance to win Ursa
is like brilliant go with it and they
win the game I mean I I was feeling bad
for Frank right I mean that's the
biggest difference in the game I you
know I I sit on the even money betting
podcast Dan I laid the points with the
Raiders because Saturday said Ellinger
was the starting quarterback ellinger's
not ready he can't play I think the
Raiders win that game and fell in your
place but they kept it secret nobody
knew Matt Ryan came out played well
Colts won that's the biggest difference
I saw
trying to figure out this Raiders
situation here you know you got a new
coach a new GM
same owner
but it feels like if anybody's going to
be Expendable after this season it's not
going to be the GM or the coach it's
going to be the quarterback
what do you think
that is interesting because if I had not
heard anybody else say that if you're
Mark Davis you need to think long and
hard about that one first of all
Derek Carr was by anybody's assessment a
top 11 quarterback last year and the
biggest reason why the team went to the
playoffs
you had a team that was very clutch won
a lot of close games down the stretch
last year made to the playoffs and you
fired the coach who did a tremendous job
because he didn't have the pedigree you
were looking for so you're bringing
McDaniels it's been a disaster Dan
disaster there's no chance that their
record would be this bad if besachio was
still there and by the way they brought
in Devonte Adams and the record still
worse if Mark Davis somebody obviously
talked Mark Davis into moving on from
Versace and mayak to go with McDaniels
if I don't know who that person is but
if they convince him to get rid of Derek
Carr for what how'd that work out the
last time McDaniels got rid of the
entrenched starting quarterback in the
city where he was coaching when he got
rid of Jay Cutler he was gone a year
later
I'm gonna play Derek Carter's press
conference
and I want you to pretend as if you're a
teammate let's say you're a lineman with
the Raiders and you hear your
quarterback say the following
I love I love Josh I love the car love
our coaches
um they've had nothing but success you
know way more success than I've ever had
and uh you know I'm sorry
Derek um you know I'm sorry continue to
finish that
sorry for being emotional
I'm just pissed off about some of the
things you know
that a lot of us try and do just to
practice what we put our bodies through
just to sleep at night
and for that to be the result of all
that effort pisses me off pisses a lot
of guys off it's hard knowing what some
guys are doing like I said just to
practice what they're putting in their
body just to sleep at night like just so
we could be there for each other
and I wish everybody in that room felt
the same way about this place and as a
leader that pisses me off from being
honest
all right some guys most of us he's
calling out somebody
there's a lot there Dan first of all he
sounded sad not angry right like when
you're angry you're not like crying
usually right you're you're not
emotional you're like I'm pissed off I'm
angry you know he's having a more sad
than he did angry to me there
um you know I I'd be curious that's one
that he has to address now I would say
behind closed doors if you're going to
say that some guys are laying it all in
the line and other guys aren't I guess
if you're one of the guys Dan that's
laying it all on the line and taking
whatever you're taking to sleep at night
I I guess you like that the quarterback
appreciates what you're doing for the
organization and for the team and if
you're a guy that feels like you're
getting called out you're probably not
real happy with it but you know what it
was funny then nobody ever really thinks
they're the one being called out no one
ever thinks it's them you know
everything they all think like they all
think that they're the guy going through
something that Derek's complimenting no
one thinks that they're the one guy not
laying it all on the line that Derek's
talking about so when Tom Brady would
say that uh when you were in New England
that hey you know not everybody's given
everything and you know you never
thought that he could be talking to you
well I wasn't there that long and he
never said that but I am sure he
wouldn't have been talking about me
because I was like the eighth of eight
oh linemen so I don't think I was really
even on his radar screen enough unless
he was talking about like what I was
doing uh drinking beers or at lunch I
don't think I don't think he'd be
referring to me uh Chargers Niners going
in opposite directions
I guess I I wasn't that impressed by the
Niners to be honest with you I mean I
Chargers are down a lot of guys I mean
they don't have their Bosa the Niners
had their Bosa and still pretty close
game I I was actually expecting more
from the Niners last night you're
playing at home you're coming off a buy
I kind of thought they would tear the
Chargers apart the Chargers hung in
there they weren't able to get it done
in the second half but the charges are
down a lot of guys I got Justin Herbert
I got six drives in the second half and
I get no points I mean
come on bad bad
I will say the Niners defense is pretty
darn good yeah
um but I I'll flip that Dan and say you
know you got Debo and McCaffrey and all
these guys and you score 22 points
against the beat up Chargers defense I
don't know I wasn't those two teams to
me are I was expecting more from the
Niners they're both middling teams I'm
not impressed well all Jimmy G does is
Win Ross
evidently yeah except for that Falcons
game and the game after that against the
Chiefs where they got killed oh you're
nitpicking there come on uh have fun
tonight okay don't screw it up
I won't gonna be a blast thank you so
much that's Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst and uh host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast also has the
even money betting podcast and you can
reach him at rosstucker NFL